[Musique]
6 enfant d'un an et demi à 17 ans une
famille de 8
[Musique]
bienvenue chez les bergers campo autant
de l'inflation avec les pieds tout ce
qui montre les sens on doit revoir nos
priorités et pour julie la priorité
c'est que ces enfants ne manquent de
rien je dois faire l'épicerie parce que
ça manque quelque chose
juste à aller on apprécie ce proche
délai aux deux jours à deux fois par
année je me permets de faire des ventes
de garage servi la sambre si avec ça
mais je suis capable par la suite de
match et rachid et vêtements aux enfants
c'est ici que j'ai store tous mes choses
soutient que des spéciaux c'est pas
toujours le cas je vais racheter comme
en plusieurs capacités c'est mon
deuxième congénères et
là comme on peut voir c'est pas tout à
fait plein justement je dois refaire des
provisions un quotidien réglé comme du
papier à musique
je me suis beaucoup sur ce qui est mon
tableau mon calendrier convenu le
calendrier scolaire
mon agenda mon téléphone sans oublier
les circulaires
saucier en outre facebook ou julie
compte aussi sur un abel l'aîné de la
fratrie qu'il est beaucoup ce que je
fais c'est que j'ai des applications
qu'on a fait mais montré récemment
phrase quoi cette semaine ou même s'ils
sont 4 99 puis aussi parce qu'ils sont 2
2 44 mais ça me coûtait 1 400 dollars
personnellement
400 dollars et comparativement bleus
quelques mois ça pouvait peut-être 2 5
925 j'arrivais à farine d'ellipses c'est
sûr que malheureusement ça me coûte
toujours plus cher de ce que je pense
c'est comme celà vignes jamais que je
vends ta chez les enfants manger parce
qu'avec le seul salaire de son conjoint
ça ne suffit plus julie a commencé à
travailler à temps partiel il ya cinq
mois j'avais envie de pouvoir aider mon
conjoint c'est la date qui avait accusé
expression mais vraiment la langue
aéronautique vêtements nourriture et
sens autant de biens essentiels dont la
famille de julie ne peut se passer et
qui risquent de gruger encore le budget
familial prix de l'essence trop bas pour
les prochaines semaines peut-être chez
moi ça pourrait commencer à monter pour
si la nourriture on s'attend à ce que ça
continue d'accélérer à raison des
changements climatiques de mauvaises
récoltes en dernier est-ce que ça vous
arrive de vous priver oui ça m'arrive
d'en priver oui son tenir à l'essentiel
pour rester à flot pour le moment on se
débrouille quand même assez bien on
n'est pas seuls d'approuver très non
plus ah non ça puis j'aimerais pas ça me
rend fou non plus mais si jamais on
arrache sait si jamais ça arrive c'est
sûr que c'est certain que oui c'est
certain que j'ai recherché live le
niveau des banques alimentaires si julie
et sa grande famille sont sortes
d'autres n'y arrive pas on est rendu à
plus de 20 % de gens qui ont un salaire
qui ont un emploi et qui arrive pas sept
acteurs communautaires qui cumule une
expertise de plus de 30 ans témoignent
d'une situation sans précédent
les prix ont tellement augmenté en
tellement quadruples et que ça n'a plus
de bon ça n'a plus de bon sens les gens
ne sont pas capables de planifier un
budget certains comptoirs de
distribution de l'aide alimentaire à
montréal se résigne à faire des choix
difficiles qu'on en arrive présentement
cette situation là où il faut choisir à
qui on donne il ya des organismes qui
font ça il y en a d'autres qui
choisissent plutôt de diminuer chaque
panier qui est donnée chez les bergers
campo la préoccupation du moment demeure
celle de passer de belles vacances en
famille en faisant ce qu'un pays nous on
vient à bordeaux
à bout de sauver sur les chambres
d'hôtel parce qu'avec l'air avec la
gagne chambres d'hôtel sont assez
dispendieuse y avait des moyens qu'on
peut faire des sorties cinq sacs horton
l'inflation affecte peut-être le
portefeuille mais pas le moral des
bergers campo
[Musique]